[Musique]
mais bonsoir à tous je dis 27 septembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal préparé
par la rédaction de tv 78 tout de suite
les titres de cette édition est la 42e
ryder cup officiellement lancée nous
serons depuis le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines où se tient la
cérémonie d'ouverture qui remportera le
duel europe etats unis lé saint
quentinois pourront en tout cas à suivre
le match depuis la fan zone installé au
centre commercial espace saint quentin à
l'occasion de la ryder cup plusieurs
villes organisent leur animation
versailles propose par exemple de venir
s'essayer au golfe face au château un
espace de 700 m² pour les débutants et
passionnés nous en parlons avec valérie
gignoux directrice des sports à
versailles et puis dans le reste de
l'actualité le rassemblement des acteurs
de la filière viande de veau rampe à
l'abattoir de houdan éleveurs et
artisans sont venus acclamer leur colère
après l attaque de plusieurs boucheries
en ile-de-france il devait faire face à
des antispécistes finalement interdite
de manifestation par la préfecture
allaient tout de suite direction le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ont rejoint amical et demi d'euros
michael vous suivez pour nous depuis le
début de la semaine cette ryder cup 2018
la compétition officielle débutera
demain et la cérémonie la cérémonie
d'ouverture mais qu'elle est en train de
s'achever
oui grégory la serbie les deux gardiens
vient tout juste de s'achever
il ya eu un des concerts la présentation
des joueurs évidemment et surtout les
matches qu'on était à dévoiler pour
demain il y aura notamment un superbe
match entre tiger woods et cisco
molinari l'italien et je suis avec des
supporters parce qu'ils étaient très
très nombreux ici quarante mille
personnes ont annoncé les organisateurs
des supporters belges qui sont juste
derrière moi alors ses supporters belges
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent de cette
ryder cup ça inouïe d'être là et de
de participer pour la première fois en
direct
j'ai participé depuis très longtemps à
la télévision vu que ça doit être la 20e
que je regarde voilà qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette cérémonie d'ouverture
extraordinaire pour nous c'est
magnifique d'être là c'est un rêve qui
devient réalité
franchement quelque chose inouïe on n'a
jamais vu ça nous ont bien de la
belgique un petit pays mais qu'il prend
tellement de choses on est des joueurs
aussi qui vont jouer la ryder cup une en
belgique mais là c'est franchement
exceptionnel
est ce que vous êtes satisfait des pères
qui ont été annoncées notamment ce
superbe match tiger woods molinari oui
oui je crois que là il ya beaucoup de
gens qui vont venir voir cette perle
rare enfin ce sont tous des tous des
pères magnifie dont je crois qu'il y
aura un grand grand spectacle et ça peut
aller de tous les côtés c'est une
cérémonie d'ouverture de la vitre
comment je crois que c'était c'est la
fête du gulf cela fait tout court or les
ravis de voir qu'en france sur ce faire
la fête merci beaucoup
en tout cas les supporters sont chauds
bouillants pour cette 42e ryder cup
merci michael et apatrides jacques de
dixmude belge est également inquiète aux
moyens techniques et si vous n'avez pas
réussi à vous procurer à des places pour
la ryder cup vous pourrez en tout cas à
suivre la compétition etats unis europe
sur écran géant une fan zone sera
installé au centre commercial espace
saint quentin à montigny le bretonneux
elle était aujourd'hui en pleine
installation la fan zone offrira dès
demain pour le début de la compétition
et ce jusqu'à dimanche
et à côté de la retransmission des
animations également le programme au
micro de mélanie poké et à des activités
culturelles et sportives une sportive
plutôt golfique
il ya du putting du practice sur l'eau
la visite du golf national en réalité
virtuelle pour permettre vraiment de de
découvrir le golf
autrement il ya l'écran géant avec la
retransmission complète de la
compétition sur les trois jours il ya du
coloriage des activités de lecture
golfique pour les enfants donc voilà ça
permet d'avoir plein d'animations autour
de la ryder cup est la fontonne
retransmettra l'événement dès demain
vendredi à partir de 8 heures début des
animations à 10 heures l accès est
gratuit à noter que 10 places pour la
ryder cup seront à gagner sur place
demain et aussi à samedi la ryder cup
c'est donc le troisième événement
sportif
le plus regardé au monde la compétition
oppose les 12 meilleurs golfeurs
américains aux douze meilleurs européens
à bilan pour le moment 26 victoires côté
américain 13 pour l'europe et deux
égalités et les états unis sont tenant
du titre après leur victoire en 2016
conserveront il leur couronne le point
sur les forces en présence avec michael
et demi d'euros deux équipes
un seul objectif sauver cette 42e ryder
cup au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
les visiteurs américains détenteurs du
titre espère bien le conserver en
alignant des top 10 ici recul mondial
comme justin thomas soit encore dustin
johnson pour conquérir une 27e ryder cup
le capitaine américain jim furyk a
également décidé de sélectionner la
super star du golf mondial tiger woods
et phil mickelson qui honorera sa 12e
sélection l'équipe américaine on la
compare à l'équipe de basket des jeux
olympiques à la dream team et c'est vrai
que c'est la dream team vous avez le
numéro un mondial qui est américain
numéro deux mondial et américains le
numéro 3 mondial est américain donc
c'est vrai que ça va être un match
fantastique
l'équipe européenne a également sorti
les muscles sur cette compétition
retrouvera des jeunes à fort potentiel
qui joueront leur première ryder cup
comme l'espagnol john rabe ou le danois
thorbjorn olesen et des joueurs
d'expérience comme le golfeur italien
francesco molinari l'anglais justin rose
et le nord irlandais rory mcilroy qui a
déjà participé à quatre éditions des
choix de thomasz viande dans les quatre
wild cards rééquilibre un petit peu la
jeunesse des joueurs qui se sont
qualifiés automatiquement vous avez des
joueurs comme stenson des joueurs comme
poulter des joueurs comme garcia qui
sont des joueurs d'expérience et qui
viendront et poulet les rocky qui eux se
sont qualifiés d'office dans cette
équipe on retrouvera également dans
cette équipe suédois alex noren
vainqueur du dernier open de france
c'est le joueur européen en forme
il s'est donc imposé il ya quelques
semaines sur ce même parcours du golf
national ça va être un homme à suivre il
est en plus particulièrement attachant
le joueur suédois
je lui prédis de nombreuses victoires en
double et en simple à la ryder cup
qui remportera ce duel de géants entre
les états unis et l'europe répond ce
dimanche 30 septembre aux alentours de
17 heures à côté des grands noms du golf
une ancienne légende du basket sera
également présent pour l'événement
michael jordan va assister à la ryder
cup à saint quentin en yvelines
le sextuple vainqueur de la nba double
médaillé olympique et et hier au parc
des princes à paris il a assisté à la
large victoire du paris saint germain
contre reims
michael jordan a récemment noué un
partenariat commercial entre sa marque
vestimentaire et le club français s est
également un grand féru de golf avec moi
au plateau une invité valérie gignoux
bon soir dans ça vous êtes la directrice
des sports de versailles alors à
l'occasion de cette 42e ryder cup la
ville et l'agglomération versailles
grand parc organise l'opération venait à
golfe et au château c'est jusqu'à
dimanche face au château pardon alors
avant de parler de cette opération
d'avoir cette ryder cup à côté de
versailles ça se passe à à saint quentin
en yvelines est ce que c'est une chance
pour la ville de versailles
bien sûr c'est une chance on essaye de
bâtir autour des grands événements
sportifs internationaux une campagne
d'animation sportive des grands autour
de ces pratiques spécifiques comme on
avait pu le faire autour de l'euro 2016
par exemple où le championnat du monde
de handball qui s'est déroulé à paris
pour les masculins
en 2010 m donc c'est important de
profiter de ces grands événements pour
vers seulement faire rayonner la
thématique sportive du moment alors
c'est important pour les habitants parce
qu'ils sont en proximité on accueille
donc les joueurs des équipes européennes
et des états unis au trianon palace à
versailles et
ça me semble important de faire
participer les populations de proximité
à l'événement ces joueurs ils dorment au
trianon palace depuis lundi ou mardi les
avoirs à versailles c'est une fierté
pour tout à fait c'est on a essayé de se
mettre un peu aux couleurs c'est ça qui
nous motive aussi c'est de montrer qu'on
accueille aussi à versailles pour cet
événement international
vous le disiez en faire profiter à vos
habitants d'ailleurs en lien avec cette
opération environ 1200 enfants de
versailles vont pouvoir ou ont déjà pu
s'initier au golf
l'idée c'est de faire découvrir ce sport
qui est encore peu populaire peut être
que la ryder cup va médiatiser ce sport
en tout cas en france
alors on espère
donc on est on est présents dont on a
été présent dans toutes les écoles enfin
dans une partie des écoles de la ville
et notamment effectivement des enfants
les plus éloignés de cette pratique
parce qu'on a des quartiers un peu
diversifiée à la ville de versailles
donc l'idée c'était d'amener le golf sur
le temps du midi pour tous les enfants
dans les écoles et ensuite d'avoir un
temps fort au moment de la compétition
sur l'avenue de paris avec cette belle
avenue et cette perspective qui nous est
offerte face au château
je crois d'ailleurs que versailles dans
le top 20 en termes de licenciés golf en
france tivement à versailles en a plus
de mille huit cents licenciés de golf
qui habite la ville et même dans l'agglo
au csa totalise un nombre supérieur à
5000 golfeurs qui sont qui sont en
proximité de versailles
donc on entend à cette opération venait
golf et face au château quelles sont les
possibilités sur place et ce que l'on
peut faire du gold que l'on soit un
initié ou seulement un débutant
effectivement c'est ouvert à tous c'est
gratuit alors effectivement les
conditions de jeu sont peut-être un peu
rupestres on va dire pour voilà on n'a
pas les greens du golf national bien sûr
mais nos collègues des espaces verts ont
quand même travaillé une qualité grâce
au comité départemental de daisy blinn
de golf on a aussi deux structures
gonflables qui permettent de faire du
practice donc petits et grands peuvent
s'amuser ça se passe sur l'avenue de
paris à quelques quelques mètres des
grilles du château de versailles qui
encadrent ces activités ce que c'est des
professionnels du golf
en partie oui puisqu'on ans collabore
avec le golf de jardy qui nous
accompagne sur cet événement et nos
éducateurs sportifs de la ville qui ont
été formés par le comité départemental
de golf des illuminés qui sont
maintenant pas des professionnels mais
qui sont formés pour accueillir le
public
alors à côté de cette opération il ya
tout un programme goal qui s'est mis en
place notamment ce matin une conférence
sur l'environnement c'est comment
concilier la pratique sportive sur des
terrains engazonnés comme c'est le cas
pour le golf et la ryder cup avec
justement les enjeux environnementaux
tout à fait puisque le
le zéro phyto et cher aversa et pour
l'entretien des terrains sportifs c'est
plus compliqué que dans les parcs et
jardins puisqu'on a des programmes des
compétitions qui nous est des dates qui
nous sont imposées et du coup qui
conditionne des traitements des gazons
qui sont un peu différents et nos amis
sportifs sont assez exigeants sur la
qualité des pelouses qu'on peut leur
mettre à disposition donc c'est une
thématique qu'on travaille et qu'on sur
laquelle on voulait échanger
c'était un peu un prétexte aussi les
golfs ont fait beaucoup de progrès
là-dessus il faut que pour les terrains
de foot et de rugby on puisse faire
beaucoup de progrès aussi dans le
traitement qu'ils sont faits au gazon en
plus de cette confiance il ya je crois
des ateliers arts plastiques y allons
proposer pour tout à fait ce monsieur
sur l'espace donc l'espace avenue de
paris
on a voulu aussi privilégier un peu le
côté culturel et l'accès tous les
enfants ne sont pas tournés vers
l'action donc ceux qui sont plus tournés
vers vers le dessin on leur a proposé de
venir customiser une balle une balle de
golf et de venir là disposés dans des
dans des réceptacles qu'on a que nos
minuit nos menuisiers ont construit à
l'éffigie de la ryder cup et de venir
déposer leurs petites balles dans ces
coupes et
voilà ça permet à tous les enfants de
prat de participer 42e édition de cette
ryder cup la semaine dernière y avait un
autre grand événement à verser 41e
édition du paris versailles qui arrivait
justement dans votre ville on sait aussi
que en 2024 il ya certaines épreuves des
jeux olympiques qui se dérouleront dans
votre ville quelles places à le sport à
versailles alors comme je le disais tout
à l'heure on essaye de construire toute
une campagne d'animation sportive autour
des grands événements sportifs
effectivement les jeux olympiques dans
six ans et c'est une belle perspective
donc on aura la chance d'avoir les
épreuves d'équitation de pentathlon
moderne et peut-être un passage des
épreuves de cyclisme
donc on va travailler c'est le
pentathlon moderne me semblent être une
une pratique qui résonne bien à
versailles ça il ya d une histoire
militaire à versailles cc sont des
disciplines qui ont été beaucoup
pratiqué par les militaires on a plein
de plein de d'équipements qu'ils peuvent
nous permettre de construire un club
peut-être autour de ça donc on a plein
de projets effectivement et et faire
participer notre population locale à ce
bel événement thoune on ira peut-être
pas avoir une épreuve des jeux
olympiques mais on espère que dans les
six années à venir on les aura fait
participer en tout cas à la construction
de cet événement je vais vous demander
comment se prépare d'ailleurs la villa à
recevoir ces événements c'est vous le
disiez travailler avec les associations
des gens en place peut être créer de
nouvelles associations sportives
exactement essayer d'animer un peu le
tissu local sportif pour pour que tout
le monde puisse y participer
c'est aussi un moyen de motivation des
agents de la ville aussi de participer
d'être en périphérie de ces événements
mais aussi de donner sa petite pierre à
l'édifice et de participer voilà c'est
un levier de motivation aussi les
épreuves qu'on parlait pas de facture
moderne pardon et équitation ça se
déroulera dans le parc du château de
versailles
alors pour partie ou l'équitation bien
sûr dans le parc du château le
pentathlon moderne
vous savez je vous demande pas quels
sont les cinq épreuves du pentathlon
moderne met donc à de la natation et
pour ça faut une piscine donc a priori
on en accueillera la natation du
pentathlon moderne dans la piscine
municipale est donc une partie des
épreuves au château si on revient à
l'opération venait golf et faso au
château l adl a débuté hier comment ça
se passe pour le moment ce qu'il fait
beau public est au rendez vous oui très
bien parce qu'il fait beau pardon et
effectivement les enfants sont ravis
beaucoup d'enfants et hier puisque
c'était mercredi et les centres de
loisirs mais des familles aussi qui qui
qui nous remercient de cette action dont
tous ne sont pas très au fait de la
ryder cup mais sacré les chants sacrés
le dialogue était aussi notre leitmotiv
quels sont vos espérances l'opération je
rappelle à se termine dimanche
quelles sont vos attentes qu est ce qu
il ferait que cette opération soit une
réussite pour la ville n'a effectivement
que les le public réponde présent parce
que là on est effectivement sur les plus
des enfants qui viennent des centres de
loisirs demain les enfin aujourd'hui et
demain des scolaires et samedis
dimanches beaucoup de familles plein de
sourires et des belles images
venez golf et face au château de
versailles l'opération se déroule
jusqu'à dimanche avenue de paris c'est
de 10h à 19h30 nocturne ce vendredi à
20h30 et dimanche rendez vous de 10h à
18h merci valérie géniaux d'avoir est
avec nous merci je rappelle que vous
êtes la directrice des sports de la
ville de versailles et toutes les
informations sur cet événement sont bien
sûr à retrouver sur le site internet de
la ville qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
pour être complet sur la ryder cup et
avant de passer à autre chose tous les
soirs jusqu'à dimanche sur tv 78
émission spéciale pour revenir sur les
principaux événements de la journée ce
soir à 18h45
vous avez rendez vous avec michael et
demi d'euros depuis le golf national
avec au programme vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure à la cérémonie d'ouverture
reportage également au sein du media
center et au près et des bénévoles et
puis lundi noté le temps aux agents
d'ahun 7,8 sport spécial pour revenir et
faire le bilan sur cette 42e édition de
la ryder cup c'est pour toujours l'an
passé saint quentin en yvelines lancé
son implication dans le dispositif sport
sur ordonnance c'est une activité
physique adaptée prescrite par un
médecin dans l'agglomération l'institut
de promotion de la
santé porte l'initiative les premières
sessions ont eu lieu en avril et ont
repris le 17 septembre mélanie poker
[Rires]
fait et pour ses participants aux
activités sportives adaptées être un
petit problème technique on vous re
proposera ce journal tout à l'heure dans
le journal en attendant cela devait être
une action antispécistes ce sont
finalement les professionnels de la
viande qui se sont fait entendre hier
agriculteurs bouchers et artisans se
sont rassemblées hier soir mercredi elle
devant l abattoir de houdan il était
initialement venu contrer une
manifestation d antispécistes ses
militants de la cause animale
mais le rassemblement a été interdite
par la préfecture des yvelines reportage
d'isabelle carré escos et nicolas dans
le riz ils étaient une centaine
d'agriculteurs bouchers et charcutiers
mercredi devant l'abattoir de 12 ans ou
la manifestation prévue dès
antispécistes a finalement été interdite
par le préfet tous ces professionnels de
la filière étaient présents pour
protester contre les récentes attaques
de boucherie notamment yvelinoise
perpétrés par ces militants de la
défense animale nous on a été caillassé
donc vous voyez là c'est ça c'est la
vitrine en vrai donc
on a subi plein d'impact de pierre et un
tag antispécistes mme c'est une grande
injustice parce que ils s'attaquent à
des gens comme nous qui ne faisons pas
de mal aux animaux
c'est pas nous qui on n'est pas là pour
leur faire du mal au contraire la
filière fait qu en sorte que tout aille
au mieux pour pour le soin des animaux
l'assemblée était également composée de
chasseurs mais aussi de quelques élus
venus soutenir le métier de boucher il
est remis en cause dans la qualité son
travail aidés dans la nature même de son
travail par des gens dont il ne connaît
même pas le visage et qui se permettent
de détruire son outil de travail
antispécistes contre professionnels de
la viande deux mondes qui ne se
comprennent pas pour les professionnels
du secteur catégorique sur cette
question c'est leur droit de pas vouloir
manger de la viande c'est notre droit de
vouloir en manger et senna droit d'en
produire et je vois pas pourquoi on
remettrait pas en cause
on demande aux pouvoirs publics de faire
en sorte que ces associant la soit
détruite fin disloqué l'abattoir de
houdon est régulièrement la cible des
antispécistes en 2016 et en avril
dernier les militants s'y était
introduit illégalement pour rendre
compte des conditions d'abattage des
porcs en 2016 plus de 7 millions
d'enfants déjeuner à la cantine au moins
une fois par semaine toute cette semaine
tv 78,2 vous faisait découvrir à
l'alimentation de nos jeunes à l'école
on a souvent l'image de repas peu à peu
appétissante et dans les yvelines de
nombreuses communes ont choisi eux
d'intégrer à des produits locaux et du
bio pour redonner du goût aux plats
c'est le cas à magny les hameaux et
attrapes mélanie poké s'est rendue dans
deux écoles primaires regarder à magny
les hameaux ce midi au menu pour les
enfants rient chou fleur et viande bien
loin de celle caoutchouteuse chanté par
carlos en 1972 depuis 2011 la commune a
choisi de passer au bio pour les 90 %
d'élèves scolarisés déjeunant à la
cantine on a voulu passer à avoir une
une restauration de qualité et 50 % de
bio
donc ça veut dire un produit laitier
donc à chaque chaque repas et soit la
viande soit le poisson soit le
un légume enfin après le deuxième
produit au choix de sodexo puisque c'est
ce dax au qui a remporté le marché à
cette époque du bio mais aussi du
circuit court les laitages comme les
yaourts ou les fromages viennent de
fermes locales comme celle de victhom de
jouer en josas et de coubertin à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse favoriser les
circuits courts pour notamment
sensibiliser au goût redonner du goût
c'est aussi l'objectif de trappes
la commune a choisi d'avoir une cuisine
centrale pour produire chaque jour 2000
repas pour ses cantines pour maîtriser
entièrement toute la chaîne de
fabrication pour maîtrisez également les
produits de base qui sont transformés et
savoir ce qu'il ya dans l'assiette de
l'enfant la qualité bio c'est déjà un
label reconnu
même si tout n'est pas parfait dans le
bio il ya quand même une avancée
positive intéressante à poursuivre et
aujourd'hui nous arrivons à avoir des
menus entier composé
de bio et parfois dans le mois des
matières des matières comme les yaourts
et fromages entièrement bio fabriqués
dans le département plus d'un million
d'euros de budget est consacré par la
commune à la cuisine centrale
chaque jour les 13 membres de l'équipe
arrive à 7 heures pour préparer le repas
des 30 office près de 780 kg de produits
sont cuisinés des produits issus
principalement du circuit court et bio
en fonction des saisons
tous les produits sont réceptionnés
entre deux et trois jours avant la date
de production
nous produisons le matin nous
conditionnement donc nous sommes dans en
liaison froide donc une production nous
cuisons nous refroidit sont avec les
normes donc
les normes d'hygiène nous mettons en
barquettes et livrons le
le matin pour le midi donc vers pas
qu'ils sont fabriqués la veille trappe
souhaite aussi que l'enfant puisse
choisir ce qu'ils mangent pour cette
rentrée la commune propose dans des
écoles pilotes un double choix pour le
plat chaud comme tous les jeudis le
portrait de la rédaction on continue ce
soir
notre découverte des femmes et hommes
qui s'investissent dans ce projet aux
artistes le patrimoine lancé par le parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse focus ce soir sur cécile
dachary une artiste qui à sa manière
redonne vie à l'abbaye des moulineaux à
poigny la forêt une rencontre signée
jules colis construite en 1166 par
l'ordre religieux de grandmont l'abbaye
des moulineaux a connu de nombreux
propriétaires et conflits avant de
tomber en ruine en 1643 un lieu
intrigant qui inspire et cécile dachary
pour le projet aux artistes le
patrimoine du parc naturel régional de
la vallée de chevreuse et beaucoup à
avoir un intérêt pour tous kervin ça
dégage toujours une ambiance est quelque
chose de très particulier il ya toujours
une espèce de nostalgie qui se dégage de
ces endroits là quand on visite une
ruine enfin moi en tout cas je ne peux
pas m'empêcher d'imaginer
quelle était la vie qui feint comment ça
résonnait comment la ville résonnait
dans cet endroit là à l'époque où il y
avait des gens qui vivaient traiter du
fond du fantôme dans ce cadre là c'est
vraiment effectivement c'est l'esprit de
tous ces gens qui sont passés là c'est
tout ce qui flotte encore et ça c'est
imprègne toujours les lieux
indéniablement couturière céramistes
photographes entre toutes ses
différentes casquettes
c'est donc celle de plasticienne que
cécile a décidé de porter pour ce projet
en créant une pièce à la signification
très particulière j'ai des signes de la
dentelle en fait avec mon pistolet à
colle j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dessiner des bâtiments j'ai fait une
ville entière comme sa piste la colle
c'est comme si j'avais c'est comme si
j'avais un crayon en fait enfin des
signes vraiment je dessine à malgré
l'improviste je vais faire une maquette
dans cette technique qui sera suspendue
dans les arbres devant un mur en ruine
qui reste aussi à distance comme un
fantôme vraiment de cette chapelle qui
reste au milieu des bois c'est un
matériau moderne entre guillemets n'est
pas très noble en fait c'est pas si
solide que ça non plus et là c'est ce
qui m'intéresse aussi dans cette pièce
qui va être suspendu pendant trois
semaines dans la forêt qui va être
laissés là et donc
comme le thème est la ruine elle va
peut-être se détruire n'a peut-être pas
résisté mais ça fait partie du jeu c'est
ce qui m'intéressait aussi c'est donc
après de nombreuses heures de travail et
près de 10 kg de colle que cette
installation nommée poétique de la ruine
sera ouverte au public les 15 16 23 et
30 septembre dans la forêt de poids ni
avant de se quitter on essaye de vous re
proposer ce reportage sur le sport sur
ordonnance l'an passé saint quentin en
yvelines lançait son implication dans le
dispositif
le sport sur ordonnance et une activité
physique adaptée prescrite par un
médecin dans l'agglomération l'institut
de promotion de la santé porte
l'initiative les premières sessions ont
eu lieu en avril elles ont repris le 17
septembre mélanie poké invisible mon
problème technique
elle n'arrive pas à rentrer dans l'ordre
désolé pour ce contretemps et on referme
ce journal pour connaître les
principales idées de sorties je vous
invite à regarder dans un instant le 7-8
culture présentée le 7 8 loisirs pardon
présenté par marylène iapichino et belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]